bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24
le 8 mai 1945 marque la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale en europe mais
en algérie ce jour porte une toute autre
signification notamment dans les villes
de sétif de guelma et de kherrata des
milliers de personnes perdent la vie
suite à une répression de l'armée
française pour évoquer cette période
sombre et ses conséquences j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir benjamin stora qui
est historien auteur de nombreux
ouvrages sur cette période et d'autre
dans la relation franco algérienne
notamment six de ces ouvrages sont
inclus dans l ouvrage une mémoire
algérienne qui est paru chez robert
laffont merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
aussi l'auteur d'un rapport commandé par
le président emmanuel macron sur les
questions mémorielles alors on va
commencer par une question toute simple
ce 8 mai 1945 était censé être un jour
de célébration que s'est il passé
notamment à sétif bien il a eu sa part
dans une manifestation précisément pour
commémorer la la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale la capitulation des
nazis et donc des milliers des milliers
de personnes dans toutes les villes
d'algérie d'ailleurs ont manifesté il y
avait eu aussi le 1er mai où paravent
quelques jours auparavant il y avait eu
des manifestations aussi d'algériens qui
ont participé à la guerre puisque des
dizaines de milliers des centaines de
milliers de soldats algériens avaient
combattu on se souvient par exemple de
monte cassino etc et donc ils ont
participé à cet effort de guerre et il
pensait être entre guillemets disant
retrait compensées ou le fait que soit
reconnu à se dire leurs droits et
notamment sur une question très
importante qui était la libération de
leurs principales leaders politiques de
l'époque qu'était messali hadj qui avait
été arrêté et déporté à brazzaville le
23 avril 1945 est donc naturellement
pour eux
pour ces militants algériens du parti du
peuple algérien le parti principal eh
bien ils subissent naturellement il
s'agissait de manifester ce jour-là en
particulier pour réclamer la libération
de messali et pour que
la france accède au droit de l'égalité
et le même de l'indépendance de
l'algérie donc ces manifestations ont eu
lieu un petit peu partout mais à sétif
effectivement il y a eu disons au début
un porteur du drapeau algérien scouts
musulmans algériens qui n'était pas
autorisé cette manifestation n'était pas
autorisée et le fait de brandir le
drapeau algérien n'était pas autorisé
non plus et les manifestants au nombre
de dix milles environ qui chantait
l'hymne national algérien miami la villa
ont manifesté par et
il y a eu un
disons un policier qui a tiré sur le
porteur du drapeau algérien ce qui a
provoqué naturellement une stupéfaction
puis ensuite une colère très grande
parmi les manifestants qui s'en sont
pris aux européens qui était là présent
donc il ya eu effectivement des
européens qui ont été tuées à sétif et
dans les environs de sétif et ensuite la
l'insurrection entre guillemets
soulèvement s'est répandu un petit peu
partout dans le constantinois dans
d'autres villes du constantinoise et 102
europe est en total ont été tués mais la
répression à tourner véritablement au
massacre d'une guerre de représailles en
fait fondamentalement qui a été qui a
été mis en oeuvre et qui a duré
pratiquement deux mois parce qu'on parle
qu'au temps du vix mai 1945 où la
répression a été très dur ce jour-là
sétif aussi à guelma avec les milices
européenne et rata mais fondamentalement
la la répression a duré deux mois c'est
en mai et juin
1945 elle a fait plusieurs milliers
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
victimes alors ce bilan est d'ailleurs
toujours un sujet de controverse le
bilan officiel côté algérien ces
quarante cinq mille morts du côté
européen c'est nettement moins alors oui
il ya effectivement eu toujours des
chiffres qui ont été avancés et
critiquer les algériens tout de suite
dès 1945 le pp a avancé le chiffre de 45
mille morts ce chiffre d'ailleurs
reconnu toujours en algérie comme étant
le chiffre officiel mais en fait après
ou avant ou après les événements
eux-mêmes de cette tragédie il ya eu
tout sur un débat effectivement il ya
plusieurs types de chiffres qui sont
avancés mais qui sont tous très
important parce que les américains par
exemple avait avancé service américain
en chute de 30 mille morts il y a aussi
des chiffres qui avaient été avancés
ensuite par l'armée française qui
parlait de 1200 morts bon des historiens
ensuite on avance et différents chiffres
je pense en particulier aux chiffres
avancés par charles robert ageron dit
gilbert meynier qui ont avancé un
chiffre entre grosso modo 8000 et 20000
morts ont ce qui est considérable et en
l'espace de quelques jours quelques
semaines c'est considérable parce que ça
veut dire qu'il ya eu des exécutions
sommaires des arrestations arbitraires
des exécutions des assassinats
n'ont pas seulement d'ailleurs par
l'armée régulière mais aussi par des
milices européenne qui avait été
constituée et ça a été une répression
absolument
épouvantable pour vous le vrai siffler
si tenté qu'il en mais c'est très
difficile à dire parce que les chiffres
ils sont connus fin pour moi c'est
colossal parce que toute façon ça tourne
entre vingt et vingt-cinq mille morts ce
qu'est ce qui est considérable à cette
période là parce que dans dans l'espace
de quelques jours seulement c'est
colossal c'est considérable et ça m'a
marqué à jamais la mémoire algérienne
bien entendu est-ce que ça a marqué
évidemment on peut imaginer que ça a été
une sorte de coup d'envoi entre
guillemets si on peut le dire comme ça
du mouvement indépendantiste algérien
mais du côté français est ce qu'il ya eu
un silence radio sur cette
période du côté algérien bien sûr les
témoignages sont très nombreux à kateb
yacine de grands écrivains algériens
disent et ce jour là que mon
nationalisme c'est si véritablement
cimenté on a les témoignages bien sûr de
faire un tabac son testament inédit il y
à d'autres beaucoup d'autres témoignages
beaucoup de livres de aussi de rites
amdh et c'est à qui tous disent que les
massacres de mai 45 en algérie en ont
véritablement marqué un tournant c'est
un marqueur
idéologique très important
dans leur engagement de nationalisme
notamment dans le ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le passage à la lutte armée deux
ans plus tard du côté français le
général de gaulle dans ses mémoires
consacre à peine de ligne seulement
alors qu'il était aux affaires cette
époque là donc pratiquement rien
des voix françaises qui se sont élevées
contre ce massacre qui a la très peu
j'en citerai simplement deux celle de
dabul caire étaient résistants qui avait
organisé le débarquement de 42 qui s'est
élevé contre ces massacres en juin 1945
la tribune de l'assemblée nationale et
puis et puis et puis albert camus qui a
protesté vigoureusement contre ces
massacres en disant que les algériens et
était considérée comme inférieure comme
des appartements une source humanitaire
en fait il appartenait à cette catégorie
à faire parce qu'on les avait conduits à
cette catégorie inférieure le système
colonial en l'occurrence camus avait des
mots très durs mais il faut signaler
qu'il a été un des rares intellectuels
français peut-être même le seul
intellectuel français en 45 à voir
l'importance qu'avait disons c'est cet
événement tragique absolument terrible
qui vont à porte qui vont amener un
durcissement du nationalisme algérien et
en 2005 c'est seulement en 2005 la
france par la voix de son ambassadeur
hubert colin de verdière l'ambassadeur
de france jeunes est reconnaître que
c'est une tragédie inexcusable c'était
un massacre le massacre sur
recommandation du président la
république de l'époque jacques chirac
qui a demandé à hubert colin de verdière
l'ambassadeur de france de reconnaître
bien sûr sur massa qui n'habite qui
n'avait pas été reconnu et ça a été
ensuite aussi le discours de bernard
bajolet en 2008 sous la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy aussi qui a reconnu
l'existence de ce massacre à guelma
guelma où la relation a été terrible et
pierre châtain aussi aux des gorges où
des centaines d'algériens ont été jetés
dans ces gorges dont il est évident que
ça a été très tardif mais il ya eu cette
reconnaissance qui a été fait et puis
ensuite un ministre français en 2015
s'est rendu déposé une gerbe sous
françois hollande sur dix ont la
reconnaissance de cet épisode cette
tragédie terrible est-ce que ce point de
vue là les mémoires sont réconciliés le
président algérien abdel majid tebboune
a instauré une journée
spécifique il y a très peu de temps pour
marquer ce jour là une journée de la
mémoire oui c'était une journée de la
mémoire je sais pas si on peut parler de
réconciliation parce que vous savez le
fait qu'on ait mis tant de temps à
regarder en face la réalité coloniale
fait qu'il ait faussé le fossé s'est
creusé je veux dire au niveau mémorial
c'était toute la difficulté de mon
rapport et de ses réceptions parce que
soixante ans après il est évident que
reconnaître un certain nombre de faits
le lemay la temporalité qui a été prise
la plus tôt plutôt l'absence de décision
qui a été prise fait que les imaginaires
sont pas les mêmes les rapports sont pas
les mêmes dans des rapports aussi
sanglant aussi tragique dans ces
massacres absolument terrible
épouvantable on a effectivement des
oppositions mémorial qu'il faut
effectivement comblé par toute une série
de petits gestes mémorielle pour
parvenir 10 ans a avancé ensemble et que
la mémoire ne soit pas un obstacle à la
fabrication l'existence d'un rapport
franco algérien alors vous avez évoqué
ce rapport il vous avait été commandée
par emmanuel macron la réception a été
limitée j'allais dire du côté algérien
est ce que vous par le président macron
à lui-même
évoquer sa frustration il a parlé de
rentrer mémorielle il a condamné le
système politico militaire alger ça a
créé une brouille diplomatique
est-ce que vous pensez que désormais
réélu il va de nouveau tenter de
réconcilier tant que faire se peut ses
mémoires vous savez sous la présidence d
manueel macro ont été réalisés un
certain nombre de gestes qui n'avait
jamais été réalisé depuis 60 ans je n'ai
pas été tous les sites et de la
reconnaissance du meurtre maurice audin
de ali boumendjel du 17 octobre 61
l'ouverture des archives et que ces
énormes tout ce qui a été accompli
pendant à peine quelques années
seulement donc c'est pas possible
d'interrompre disons ce processus qui
effectivement a démarré en france sans
attendre effectivement qu'il y ait la
possibilité de faire quelque chose en
commun avec l'algérie il fallait
rattraper comme celle évoquée tout à
l'heure il fallait rattraper ce retard
et donc à partir de là je crois pas
qu'on puisse interrompre ce processus
paiement riels de reconnaissance il va
se poursuivre il va continuer enfin je
le pense ne serait ce que parce que dans
mon rapport il ya encore des
préconisations qui n'ont pas étaient
encore appliquée réalisé prise en compte
par exemple l'entrée de gisèle halimi au
panthéon qui a été militant pour
l'indépendance de l'algérie la
constitution disons d'un d'un musée
d'histoire pourquoi pas de la france et
de l'algérie à montpellier sur des
choses importantes mais à d'autres
encore recommandations que j'avais dix
ont préconisé notamment sur la question
des essais nucléaires c'est aussi une
question extrêmement lourdes extrêmement
importante bref je crois pas qu'on
puisse s'arrêter dans ce chemin tel
qu'il est pris maintenant depuis
plusieurs années donc vous pensez que
les manuels macron pourrait le faire
peut-être se rendre à alger ou recevoir
la visite de monsieur teboul initiale de
toute façon entre entre paris et alger
il ya la nécessité et toute façon d'un
accord qui pas simplement disons
1 une entente qui se situent
exclusivement sur le plan mémoriel il ya
énormément de défis et d'enjeux sur le
plan international qui fait que de toute
manière la coopération entre paris et
alger va se poursuivre sur le plan
disons des éditions du pétrole du gaz
des questions migratoires les questions
de sécurité notamment en afrique donc de
toute façon cette hausse est de
coopération aller te j'allais presque
dire inévitable mais il ne faut pas que
la question mémorielle se transforme en
un obstacle à cette coopération tout à
fait normales et classiques entre deux
états
benjamin stora merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur le plateau de france 24 et
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien rester sur nos antennes pour
plus d'informations
[Musique]